bonsoir à tous le préfet de la région
corse a été assassiné de plusieurs
balles dans la tête ce soir ajaccio par
deux inconnus
il était un peu plus de 21h et claude
erignac a été abattu en pleine rue alors
qu'il sortait de sa voiture c'est la
première fois qu'un haut fonctionnaire
de l'état est assassiné en corse les
faits william irigoyen c'est à 21h15 que
claude erignac a trouvé la mort le
préfet de la région corse a été
assassiné devant le complexe de loisirs
du kallisté en plein centre d'ajaccio
claude erignac se rendait avec son
épouse à un concert
il venait de descendre de sa voiture
lorsque deux personnes peut être plus se
sont précipités sur lui ils ont tiré
plusieurs coups de feu dans le dos de
claude erignac
les services de police aurait retrouvé
un pistolet à proximité du lieu de
l'assassinât
on ne connaît pas pour l'heure le
calibre de l'armé utilisée
âgé de 60 ans claude erignac avait été
nommé préfet de corse en janvier 80
cents cet assassinat intervient deux
semaines après l annonce par le flnc
canal historique de la fin de la trêve
des attentats
mais pour le moment rien ne permet
d'affirmer qu'il s'agit là d'un
assassinat politique
claude erignac est le premier haut
fonctionnaire de l'état assassiné dans
l'île philippe seguin président du rpr
exprime ce soir son sentiment d'horreur
devant un acte de sauvagerie aussi
insensé et laurent fabius président de
l'assemblée nationale estime qu'il
s'agit là d'un acte odieux qui appelle
la condamnation la plus ferme
claude erignac était préfet de la région
corse depuis janvier 96 il avait 60 ans
et l'essentiel de sa carrière s'était
déroulée dans le corps préfectoral
portrait avec cette correspondance
signée jacques cardoze il prêt comme
doit l'être un préfet surtout en corse
claude erignac n'avait jamais suscité le
moindre sentiment de haine à son égard
jamais claude erignac n'avait enfreint
les codes en vigueur dans l'île il était
à la fois respectueux de l'identité
corse et tenter d'être le digne
représentant de l'état à l'état si
difficile à appliquer dans l'île un
homme dont jamais personne n'a eu à se
plaindre
âgé de 60 ans il a été nommé en 96 après
une carrière qui l'a mené du pas de
calais à l'île de beauté en passant par
le gère selon nos informations
rien ne laissait présager un tel acte
dans la vie d'un homme resté dans
l'ombre
bonjour a tous eu un attentat sans
précédent a été commis hier soir en
corse le préfet de cette région c'est à
dire le plus haut représentant de l'état
dans cette île a été abattu en pleine
rue à ajaccio lionel jospin et
jean-pierre chevènement sont partis pour
la corse ce matin la classe politique
condamne unanimement cet attentat nous
écouterons tout à l'heure les réactions
et en premier lieu celle du chef de
l'état mais d'abord les faits avec
michèle fines pascal douce est bon et
emmanuel bec ses assassins ne lui ont
laissé aucune chance trois balles dans
la tête de calibre 9 mm tirées dans le
dos il est un peu plus de 21h hier soir
le préfet erignac vient de garer sa
voiture pour napoléon
il se dirige à pied vers le théâtre
kallisté car il va au concert at il été
suivi quelqu'un at-il prévenu de son
arrivée les meurtriers placé en
embuscade
c'est une hypothèse les assassins sont
jeunes peut être moins de 20 ans et sont
de type maghrébin des témoins les ont
vus car ils n'ont même pas pris la peine
de cacher leurs visages l'un d'eux porte
une casquette
ils sont en jean pull et blouson après
avoir tiré et s'enfuit à pied qu'on
appelait ont un témoin voit deux jeunes
de type maghrébin à monter dans une
voiture garée à quelques mètres du lieu
du crime
il relève le numéro d'immatriculation
une heure plus tard la police arrête les
propriétaires du véhicule
ils sont actuellement confrontés aux
témoins sur les lieux du crime les
enquêteurs ont retrouvé six douilles et
surtout le pistolet un beretta 9 mm
larmes a été volée en septembre lors de
l'attaqué d'une gendarmerie à
pietrosella au sud de la corse un acte
attribué selon les policiers à une
branche dissidente du flnc canal
historique au srpj d'ajaccio
l' enquête progresse les trois jeunes
arrêtés hier soir sont toujours en garde
à vue mais les témoins ne les aurais pas
identifié et policiers vont donc
chercher sur leurs mains des traces de
poudre afin de savoir s'ils sont ou non
les meurtriers en fin de matinée le juge
gilberte il est le chef de la section
antiterroriste du parquet de paris et
reims tolère sont arrivés à l'aéroport
d'ajaccio
ils viennent dirige l enquête le
ministre de l'intérieur est arrivé ce
matin à ajaccio jean pierre chevènement
demain
corses de se mobiliser pour permettre à
la vérité d'éclater la population est
sous le choc
atterré et indigné jacques cardoze
jean-françois giorgetti geste
inqualifiable semble dire cet homme au
petit jour
l'ambiance est lourde pesant c'est le
représentant de la république qui a été
abattu hier soir et ce matin tous ont le
visage grave
emile zuccarelli premières personnalités
à se rendre au chevet du défunt d'un
homme qu'ils connaissent album direct
justement sont d'un abord d'un abord
facile se déplaçant je dirais bien plus
sans requérir de protection particulière
mais l'émotion la plus forte la plus
palpable en tout cas et dans la rue des
fleurs et des mots pour témoigner ici un
registre de condoléances a été ouvert je
voulais dire tous mes regrets pour le
peuple corse parce qu'on représente
parce que je suis corse avant tout fut
menée ici j'ai toujours vécu ici et ça
ça ne se fait pas c'est pas de chez nous
mes yeux sur mes choix comme ça pour me
voir comme ça on devient pire que qu'au
texas n'est pas possible
par la colère par l'émotion les corps
s'exprime un peu de leur écoeurement
oui il s'agit d'un aveu d'impuissance
dit leurs représentants à l'assemblée de
corse pour l'entente c'est vrai souvent
les mêmes litanies et tous les
responsables politiques vont être mises
hâtive tiennent toujours le même propos
les cantons a atteint le paroxysme
il n'y a sans doute autre chose à faire
est de l'état j'attends sa détermination
et de notre communauté
j'attends une manifestation de dignité
et d'espérance
toujours la même litanie toujours le
même scénario au lendemain d'un tel
événement renforts de police dans les
rues de la ville bientôt dans toute la
corse avec l'arrivée du gipn
pendant ce temps le ministre de
l'intérieur réclame l'aide de toute la
population
je voudrais demander à tous nos
concitoyens de nous aider pour faire la
vérité car un homme est mort c'est celui
qui représentait la république en corse
et ils étaient abattus dans des
conditions de l'acheter je crois qu'il
en va de l'avenir de la corse
si nous voulons pas sombrer dans une
régression barbare en attendant les
progrès de l'anc est le premier ministre
lionel jospin est venu lui aussi
témoigné de son émotion auprès de la
famille du défunt
clôturant ainsi une matinée de deux
actes considérable par la force du
symbole l'assassinât du préfet claude
erignac est la plus grave atteinte à
l'autorité de l'état
jamais enregistrés en corse jacques
chirac les nageuses pas et plusieurs
membres du gouvernement viennent
d'annoncer qu'ils participeront lundi
ensemble ajaccio a nommage solennelle
dans ce journal
nous reviendrons sur la condamnation et
l'indignation unanime de la classe
politique après cet attentat mais
d'abord les faits il était un peu plus
de 21h en plein centre d'ajaccio
lorsque le préfet a été tué de plusieurs
balles ce soir trois suspects sont en
garde à vue et pourraient être
directement lié à l'attentât michèle
fines jacques cardoze et jean-françois
giorgetti on ne sait toujours pas ce
soir qui a assassiné le préfet erignac
depuis hier deux hommes sont en garde à
vue
la police avait effectué des
prélèvements sur leurs mains et leurs
bras pour tenter d'y trouver des résidus
de poudre
les premiers résultats connus il y à une
heure sont partiellement négatif ces
deux marocains d'à peine 20 ans ont été
arrêtés hier une heure après le meurtre
un témoin avait cru les reconnaître tout
près du lieu du crime
selon cet homme les assassins étaient
comme de type maghrébin et porter la
même tenue vestimentaire casquette jean
et blouson certain nombre d' expertise
qui sont menées mais même si cette piste
se verrait elle ne conduirait pas
certainement aux véritables
commanditaires
cet après midi la police judiciaire est
revenu sur les lieux du crime
minutieusement les enquêteurs refonde
jour les constatations qu'ils ont déjà
effectué de nuit
ils savent que les assassins ont tiré
trois balles en pleine tête
l'arme du crime un beretta 9 mm et
mènera peut-être jusqu'au commanditaire
le pistolet a été dérobée il ya six mois
dans l'attaqué d'une gendarmerie à
pietrosella en corse du sud
un acte attribué à une branche
dissidente du flnc canal historique ce
matin la concorde façade légale de ce
flnc a préféré condamné le crime
comment bien sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
et surtout nous dénonçons
malheureusement une fois de plus les
dérives qui ont pu amener à cette
situation
irène scolaire chef de la section
antiterroriste du parquet de paris qui
dirige les enquêtes a encore beaucoup à
faire
la police judiciaire continue quant à
elle ses investigations
de leur côté les hommes du raid et de
l'office central de répression du
banditisme ont débarqué sur l'île
discrètement à la mi-journée une
rejoignant maintenant direct à ajaccio
benoît duquesne benoît l'enquète on l'a
dit progresse actuellement trois
personnes sont placées en garde à vue et
leur signalement correspondre et au type
maghrébin
absolument et 6,7 cette piste se se
vérifier bien il faudrait expliquer
comment des nationalistes corses peuvent
être amenés à faire appel pour lutter
contre dans leur lutte contre la france
à faire appel à des hommes ou des jeunes
hommes donné société marocaine alors
d'après les spécialistes de la lutte
antiterroriste et bien ça ne serait pas
tout à fait une surprise en tout cas pas
une première puisque dans d'autres faits
mineurs cela a fait en tout cas moins
graves
eh bien on a déjà vu des petits malfrats
de banlieue quelquefois d'origine
étrangère enrôlé comme ça par des
nationalistes pour poser une bombe ici
ou là notamment dans le sud de la france
mais si ce n'est pas forcément une
surprise en tout cas ce serait quand
même le signe d'une certaine
déliquescence de ce mouvement
on pourrait dire qu'il s'agit d'une
sorte de mercenaire utilisé par des
organisations clandestines dissidente
alors c'est un petit peu toute la
question c'est là dessus qu'on a
beaucoup insisté monsieur jospin et
monsieur chevénement savoir qui manipule
éventuellement qui commandite qui a pu
armer les bras de ses jeunes si encore
une fois ce sont tout ce qui n'est pas
prouvé pour l'instant pour réfuter quand
même l'un des actes les plus des
terroristes les plus importants qu'il
puisse exister assassiné un préfet de la
république alors dans un premier temps
par an pense bien sûr au flnc canal
historique pourquoi et bien pour toutes
sortes de raisons d'abord parce que ils
ont mis frein à la trêve qu'ils avaient
eux mêmes décidé au lendemain de
l'arrivée des socialistes au pouvoir
ensuite parce que la personnalité du
préfet claude erignac en tout cas son
arrivée pouvait pour eux être synonyme
de
le changement de politique de monsieur
juppé quand il est avait décidé de
laisser tomber certaines négociations
clandestine au profit des arrestations
à commencer par celle de françois
santoni qui était l'un des deux robes de
leur leader et puis il ya la proximité
des élections régionales ou
territoriales comme on dit ici et là on
peut imaginer qu'un mouvement comme
celui-là est en vie de réapparaître
brutalement sur la scène politique
alors qu'il est en perte de vitesse mais
tout cela n'est pas aussi simple d'abord
parce que la plupart des mouvements
nationalistes ce soir condamne cet
attentat
et puis ensuite parce que cette mouvance
se déchirent de mois en mois de plus en
plus en de multiples groupuscules et
qu'il est très difficile de les
contrôler et bien évidemment de savoir
ce qu'ils font et que cela permet toutes
les surenchères les trois couleurs de la
république et l'uniforme de claude
erignac habille son dernier adieu à
l'île de beauté son épouse souhaitait
ramener le corps aujourd'hui sur le
continent
trois cents personnes sont venues à la
préfecture tout parle de l'image bafoués
de la corse d'un au revoir nécessaire à
l'homme et d'un hommage pudique à sa
fonction
au mondial va tourner part parce que
cette atteinte à la démocratie
je dirai à la corse à la france à la
république a au fond de nous chacun est
responsable parce que si on n'avait pas
laissé la violence se banalise et on
n'en serait peut-être pas là aujourd'hui
le long du cortège certains se signent
tous se taisent claude erignac a
traversé pour la dernière fois à ajaccio
la ville qu'ils avaient appris à aimer à
l'aéroport les élus les décideurs
économiques de la région l'attendent
le préfet était un négociateur ferme
mais ouvert tous sont d'accord là dessus
quant au collaborateur du préfet très
ému il évoque un homme affable et riche
d'esprit amoureux de cinéma de sport et
de musique bien sûr comme son épouse et
ses enfants
il se sentait bien en corse claude
erignac sera enterré mardi à montbrun
dans la vallée du tarn dans la plus
stricte intimité
depuis plusieurs heures ils attendent
voisins amis simples particuliers peu de
mots juste une présence symbole
d'affection demain et après demain
toutes les grosses villes n'est pas nous
pas les jungles pas les mains du village
alors on lui a dit au revoir aujourd'hui
le convoi passe en silence
seuls les proches sont admis autour de
la maison du préfet les gendarmes ont
établi un périmètre interdit
conformément aux souhaits de la famille
claude erignac reposera ici mardi
ses cendres seront disposés dans une
urne au côté de celle de sa mère un
office d'espérance et d'appels à la paix
sera célébré par le pasteur l'ep les
chrétiens de corse devraient se
mobiliser pour faire vivre ces valeurs
alors que tant de messages et de mort
veulent mettre en péril notre société
le village de montbrun est en état de
choc il y a cinq jours ici même le
préfet était venu en visite privée
il a voulu voir son ami monsieur le
préfet veille chez qui il a partagé le
repas mardi dernier il serait resté cinq
ou six jours de plus
peut-être que l'attentât n'aurait pas
selon les 60 habitants suivront demain
avec intérêt la cérémonie d'ajaccio
attentifs aux propos des officiels sur
la corde bien sûr mais surtout à
l'hommage rendu à l'enfant du pays puis
vendredi soir nombre d'hommes politiques
en corse et sur le continent ont évoqué
à propos de cet assassinat l'ombre de la
mafia le grand mot est lâché
mais il faut rester très prudent car si
effectivement la corse connaît une
dérive mathieu mafieuse depuis plusieurs
années la situation dans li na encore et
c'est heureux rien à voir avec ce qui se
passe en sicile même si le risque d'une
semblable situation n'est pas à écarter
hervé brusini palerme affiche le deuil
drapeau retenu geste solidaire adressé à
la corse
ici l'on sait ce que mafia veut dire
ajaccio la mafia on en parle aussi dans
cette cité bouleversé par la mort de son
préfet on en parle même comme une piste
possible pour expliquer son assassinat
c'est l'occasion de mettre un terme à
cette dérive dont les arrière-plans semi
mafieux ne sont que trop apparents
question l'intégrité du préfet est elle
devenue une gêne pour ces arrière-plan
semi mafieux sur le territoire le
représentant de l'état avait exercé son
autorité ici en particulier un cadre
superbe une affaire à saisir l'armé vend
son patrimoine incita les deux mots lors
de bonifacio s'étend sur une superficie
de 35 m² et déjà s'avance le projet de
construire un hôtel et un casino
pas question dire à claude erignac le
haut fonctionnaire et soupçonneux
l'argent qui se cache derrière le projet
semble fort douteux blocage de la vente
aux enchères au grand dam de l'auteur du
projet qui n'est pas au bout de ses
peines
un an plus tard le différend se déplace
vers ajaccio c'est au tour du casino de
se voir refuser son plan de
développement
voilà trop de machines à sous à deux pas
d'un établissement scolaire dira lé
préfet décidément après le refus de
l'achat de la caserne l'homme du casino
c'est le même petit parrain local était
dans le collimateur de la préfecture un
autre paradis corse avait attiré les
convoitises
les îles lavezzi et cavallo cavallo
résidence pour milliardaires souvent
plastique est miraculeusement épargné
ensuite contre rétribution un haut lieu
de l'imbrication entre mouvance
nationaliste et mafia
selon le journal le monde un rapport de
la direction de la protection et la
sécurité de la défense a d'ailleurs mis
en lumière le rôle d'un homme lié à la
mafia italienne
un rôle actif dans plusieurs de ses
projets immobiliers dans les années 80
3,85
un policier avait évoqué et dérives
mafieuses de lille
quelle époque déjà il fallait pas trop
en parler parce que vraiment dans le
mouvement nationaliste ne voulait pas
l'admettre et ça peut être été les
causes d'ailleurs essentiel des
divergences par la suite les décisions
l'argent du racket les trafics en tous
genres et détournement de l'argent
public
la mafia sicilienne s'en est fait une
spécialité mais à une toute autre
échelle
quarante mille hommes constitueraient
les troupes de la mafia poids financier
230 milliards de francs l'équivalent de
la firme fiat
et quand on parle aux spécialistes d'une
association possible avec la corse
selon moi les grandes associations
mafieuses italiennes ne se sont jamais
associé aux corses et corse le préfet
erignac n'aurait donc contrecarrer ce
qui n'est encore qu'une dérive mafieuse
la clé de son assassinat était la
rechercher sur cette piste
en tout cas cette dérive constituent
maintenant une cible claire pour l'état
la corse un nouveau préfet jean pierre
chevènement a fait le voyage pour
installer bernard bonnet qui a aussitôt
pris ses fonctions à ajaccio une semaine
le jour pour jour après l'assassinât de
claude erignac bernard bonnet décrit
comme un homme énergique est capable a
rencontré tout à l'heure les élus de
l'île
il est pour le ministre de l'intérieur
l'homme qu'il faut à l'endroit qu'il
faut
reportage agnès vahramian emmanuel bec
[Musique]
l'hommage de bernard bonnet aux morts
pour la force l'inclinaison et rituels
pour un préfet qui entre en fonction
mais cet après midi la cérémonie n'avait
rien d'une formalité
présentation solennelle des anciens
combattants des élus à un préfet dont on
flatte la fermeté des hommes politiques
premiers concernés par la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur la gestion de
l'argent public en corse
représentant la place politique qui nous
paraît insupportable de la voit remettre
en cause à tout bout de champ et de
confondre tout le monde avec n'importe
qui il est temps que les choses soient
dites clairement il ya des élus qui sont
dignes de respect peut-être et l'habile
d'autre que de son - comme je peux
apprécier un préfet arrivé quelques
heures plus tôt sous haute surveillance
accompagné avec force symbole par jean
pierre chevènement l'état signifie la
venue du ministre de l'intérieur ne
saurait se laisser intimider le palais
lantivy bernard bonnet connaît bien les
lieux il était ici préfet de police de
juillet 91 à octobre 92 et ému ce matin
d'y revenir
sa mise en place fut l'occasion pour
jean pierre chevènement de lancer un
message
j'attends de nos concitoyens corse
ils nous aident
à faire la lumière plusieurs dizaines
d'appels ont été reçus sur le numéro
vert mais d'autres moyens existent pour
vous aider à arrêter les assassins
bernard bonnet sera jugé sur ses actes
car pour beaucoup de corses sa venue
après les grandes manifestations de rue
et peut-être une chance de retrouver
confiance en l'état
dix mois après l'assassinât du préfet de
corse claude erignac l' enquête
progresse selon son successeur bernard
benêt après de nombreuses
interpellations dans les milieux
nationalistes agricole 5 membres du
syndicat des enseignants corse ont été
arrêtés cette semaine une nouvelle voie
une nouvelle piste pour les enquêteurs
michel jean
en fait ce n'est pas à proprement parler
une nouvelle piste c'est plutôt ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une piste
complémentaires les enquêteurs de la
division nationale antiterroriste sont
partis sur un tuyau des rg une
indiscrétion désignant quelques
intellectuels de la mouvance
nationaliste en particulier un prof
d'histoire-géo d'une trentaine d'années
qui s'appelle philippe castella et
policiers auraient retrouvé chez lui des
plans des traces de repérage effectué
pour préparer un attentat commis sur le
continent contre un rectorat cet
attentat aurait été commis contre l'avis
de la direction du flnc canal historique
qui aurait exclu à ce moment là philippe
castella ce prof d'histoire géo et donc
un dissident du mouvement et c'est
intéressant
chez lui les policiers auraient retrouvé
des éléments pour le moins troublant en
particulier un ordinateur et une
imprimante du même type que ceux qui ont
permis de rédiger et d'imprimer le texte
revendiquant l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
attention en aucun cas ce n'est qu'une
preuve car les spécialistes de
l'informatique sont aujourd'hui
incapables de dire si c'est cette
imprimante précisément qui a édité ou
non la revendication mais c'est un
élément les juges antiterroristes vont
mettre en examen philippe castella il
s'intéresse désormais à ses
fréquentations ils veulent savoir s'ils
étaient proches de certains agriculteurs
de la plaine orientale encore ce aussi
dissident du flnc canal historique car
ce qu'on appelait la piste agricole
cette fameuse piste explorée depuis le
début par les magistrats et les
policiers cette piste n'est pas
abandonnée en corse dix mois après
l'assassinât du préfet erignac les
enquêteurs semblent se tourner vers
d'autres pistes que celles du monde
agricole suivie jusqu'à présent depuis
la semaine dernière c'est en effet chez
les enseignants nationaliste que les
derniers
interpellation et mises en examen ont eu
lieu un milieu qui ne reste pas sans
réagir alain chabod christian walter un
convoi de voitures de police sur
l'aéroport en fait le transfert vers
paris en milieu de semaine dernière de
plusieurs militants du milieu enseignant
parmi eux jean castela depuis mise en
examen pour association de malfaiteurs
en marge du dossier erignac
les enquêteurs reprocherait à ce
professeur d'histoire géographie en
poste dans ce lycée de bastia d'être
impliqué dans la préparation et la
revendication de certains attentats
ça relève systématiquement de l'afrique
monsieur castelas est passé à strasbourg
plus tard il intente à strasbourg donc
forcément monsieur castelas y est pour
quelque chose
et si monsieur cas cela n'a pas pris
l'avion le soir parce que monsieur
caisses de l'avs en ville se divertir il
ya forcément un relais deçà de ce qu'on
appelle la construction d'intrigants
histoire ça hein on appelle ça le
révisionnisme jean castela aujourd'hui
incarcéré était également chargé de
cours ici à la faculté de corte dans une
filière tourisme pour la formation de
guides professionnels
il organisait donc régulièrement des
stages sur le continent pour ces
étudiants
son interpellation est une surprise
jamais pour pour l'enseignant qui
auraient engagé jamais aucun discours
politique n'a été intégré dans ses cours
en aucun cas d'autres parmi ces
étudiants ont été inquiétés comme cette
jeune femme encore choqués par ces douze
heures de garde à vue
je me suis en train de dire mademoiselle
vous avez la liberté de pensée ce qui
est autorisé par la loi
je vous laisse méditer cette phrase et
si tout simplement l'officialisation du
délit d'opinion avec ses 3500 étudiants
l'université de corte fait figure de
creuset culturel du nationalisme mais
jamais jusqu'ici la division nationale
antiterroriste ne s'y était intéressé
dans l' enquête sur le meurtre du préfet
aujourd'hui nous pouvons être quand même
inquiet lorsque l'on voit l'état passé
de la piste agricole à la piste
enseignante sans aucune sans aucun
élément cela pour nous cela s'apparente
à la chasse aux sorcières alors en signe
de désapprobation étudiants et
enseignants appellent ici à une
manifestation hier la veuve du préfet de
corse claude erignac assassiné en
février 98 s'interrogeait dans un
communiqué l agence france presse sur le
remue ménage entre policiers et juges
dans l' enquête sur cet assassinat
cette polémique agace manifestement de
mise l'intérieur reportage michèle fines
et jérôme soûlard sait depuis longtemps
une rumeur c'est devenu une certitude
ces deux hommes se détestent pourtant
ils travaillent ensemble ils sont co
saisis dans l' enquête sur l'assassinât
du préfet erignac
d'un côté le très médiatique jean louis
bruguière pionniers de l'antiterrorisme
de l'autre gilberte il un juge venue de
nancy depuis son arrivée en 1995 au sein
du pool antiterroriste l'ambiance n'est
pas au beau fixe
c'est une fuite au niveau de l' enquête
qui a tout déclenché il y a quinze jours
le canard enchaîné et l'est républicain
publie les extraits d'un rapport de
police le parquet de paris ouvre
immédiatement une information judiciaire
recel de violation du secret de
l'instruction
en clair un juge est chargé de trouver
d'où vient la fuite au sein du pool
antiterroriste l'heure est aux soupçons
la sphère revient sur la place publique
hier la famille erignac a fini par
demander dans un communiqué que les
juges ou bhl y leur querelle
il faut que les gens travaillent
ensemble se fasse confiance et il est
clair que si les magistrats ne travaille
pas main dans la main
entre d'abord puis ensuite avec les
services de police on n'aboutira jamais
je crois qu'il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités chacun reprenne son
calme et la famille ne demande que cela
à la sortie du conseil des ministres ce
matin jean pierre chevènement était
aussi c'est toute polémique est
regrettable il y a un intérêt et un seul
c'est l'intérêt de l'enquète et de son
aboutissement
tout le reste est subalterne voire
nuisible jean louis bruguière gilberte
il est laurence le vert le troisième
juge chargé de l'enquêté
tous ont été entendus au palais de
justice un magistrat recherche toujours
l'auteur de la fif l'activité judiciaire
continue concernant les dossiers en
cours en corse que l'interpellation de
mathieu filidori et son transfert ce
soir à paris pour être présenté au juge
jean louis bruguière a été réalisée dans
le strict cadre du dossier de
l'assassinât du préfet claude erignac
l'explication michèle fines samedi après
midi ils défilent et à ajaccio parmi les
nationalistes
mais se faisait discret mathieu filidori
savait qu'à n'importe quel moment la
justice pouvait venir lui demander des
comptes
depuis plusieurs mois dans l' enquête
sur l'assassinât du préfet erignac
mathieu filidori éleveurs représenter la
piste agricole au centre de l'accusation
ce texte écrit par mathieu filidori en
1979 est diffusée depuis à plusieurs
milliers d'exemplaires en lisant des
revendications d'attentats liés à
l'assassinât du préfet erignac
les policiers ont retrouvé des
expressions des phrases entières de ce
texte
cette phrase notre violence et
résistance notre violence légitime car
elle invente et populaire qui se
dressent pour devenir souverain selon
les enquêteurs
mathieu filidori pourrait donc être l'un
des auteurs de la revendication de
l'assassinât du préfet erignac
jamais je n'aurais été mais collet
quelque chose en confiance ce qui a pu
être dit et aidé par mois en 79
je leur ai jamais été recopiées
s'assurer sur un suresnes paragraphe qui
ne correspondent pas du tout à ce que je
pense il faudrait que je sois soit lille
à l'origine mathieu filidori devait être
mise en examen en janvier avant la date
anniversaire de l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
les fuites dans la presse ont retardé le
projet
cinq mois plus tard l'épousé du préfet
bonnet affirme dans une interview que
l'anc at erignac a échoué mathieu
filidori et arrêté le lendemain
ce n'est peut être qu'une coïncidence
cela prouve en tout cas que l' enquête
avant bonsoir la police resserre son
étau sur le milieu nationaliste corse
après un premier coup de filet hier elle
a procédé à deux nouvelles
interpellations aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur l'assassinât du
préfet erignac la police qui posséderait
de nouvelles pistes de nouveaux éléments
le point avec christophe bardy et
l'explication de christophe bardet sans
doute dans un instant sur cette série
d'interpellations qui a commencé hier
exprimer sa convocation
la soeur dallas ferrandi a finalement
été entendu cet après midi par les
enquêteurs de l'hôtel de police
d'ajaccio audition également des parents
du nationaliste corse ce matin ce qui
porte à 11 le nombre des interpellations
en 48 heures hier la police procédait en
effet à l'arrestation d'alain ferrandi
ainsi que de six de ses proches
ferrandi qui est aux yeux des forces de
l'ordre le chef d'un groupe nationaliste
en corse du sud
mais il est surtout un fidèle de jean
castela un autre nationaliste incarcéré
en novembre 98 les deux hommes font
figure de principaux suspects dans
l'assassinât du préfet érignac le 6
février 98 il aurait conversé avec leur
portable le soir même du meurtre aussi
bien avant qu'après l'acte la police a
d'ailleurs saisi hier des listings de
leur appel les dernières arrestations
encore s'inscrivent dans le cadre d'une
enquête
longue et périlleuse c'est à partir de
l'arme du crime retrouvée sur les lieux
que les policiers ont d'abord expliqué
les attentats de pietrosella de vichy et
de strasbourg perpétré quelques mois
auparavant
ces attentats auraient selon toute
vraisemblance servi à préparer le
meurtre du préfet la piste agricole est
alors explorées elle permettra
l'arrestation de deux hommes à commencer
par marcel lorenzoni à partir de cette
arrestation et des multiples auditions
qui suivront un deuxième homme est
arrêté
mathieu filidori c'était jeudi dernier
il a été mis en examen pour complicité
d'assassinats il est accusé d'être
l'auteur de plusieurs revendications
d'actes terroristes
deux interpellations en trois jours en
corse où les policiers multiplient leurs
opérations dans le cadre de l' enquête
sur l'assassinât du préfet erignac
c'est encore dans la région de cargèse
dans le sud de l'île que la division
nationale antiterroriste est intervenu
aujourd'hui pour arrêter deux hommes
stefan grand pierre julien pierre cette
fois c'est dans la région de cargèse que
les hommes de l'adn athées ont mené une
nouvelle opération policière la
troisième en trois jours ils ont
interpellé aujourd'hui les deux fils
d'un ancien député des alpes maritimes
en tout ce sont douze personnes proches
des milieux nationalistes qui ont été
placés en garde à vue ces derniers jours
un brusque coup d'accélérateur dans l'
enquête sur l'assassinât de claude
erignac due aux expertises pratiquées
sur les téléphones porta de certains de
ses protagonistes des expertises qui
selon les enquêteurs peuvent affirmer
aujourd'hui que ses hommes se trouvaient
dans le périmètre
le soir de l'assassinât à ce jour une
seule personne a été mise en examen
il s'agit de mathieu philidor il est
écroué depuis jeudi soir pour complicité
d'assassinât pour son avocat ces
opérations successives ne sont ni plus
ni moins que des manoeuvres de diversion
je pense que cette nouvelle procédure
est en réalité un contre-feu allumé par
le juge bruguière à la demande notre
probablement de 800 à l'intérieur pour
atténuer les incendies de la paillote
qui est en train de prendre des
proportions démesurées pour le
gouvernement la plupart des personnes
interpellées devraient être entendues
d'ici mardi par le juge bruguière en
charge du dossier
madame monsieur bonsoir les auteurs de
l'assassinât du préfet claude erignac le
6 février 1998 à ajaccio serait
aujourd'hui identifiées selon les
enquêteurs le commando était composé
d'au moins cinq hommes du milieu
nationaliste corse
quatre d'entre eux seraient détenus par
la police l'auteur présumé des coups de
feu serait toujours en fuite
ajaccio michèle fines et diane richard
l'un après l'autre
deux des quatre hommes du commando
arrêtés encore ce vendredi matin ont
quitté les locaux de la division
nationale antiterroriste
didier maranelli comptable de sagone a
déjà été mises en examen dans la soirée
pour assassinats
les deux autres seront transférés au
palais de justice pour être mise en
examen demain matin tous les gardés à
vue à l'exception d'un seul aurait avoué
leur participation au meurtre
les policiers connaissent désormais le
rôle de chacun selon les enquêteurs
alain ferrandi un employé de l' agence
de location hertz serait l'un des
organisateurs de l'assassinât le 6
février 98 vers 21h ils se seraient
postés à l'arrivée du préfet près du
théâtre kallisté didier maranelli lui
aurait donné le signal du départ de la
voiture à la sortie de la préfecture
pierre alessandri un parfumeur aurait
servi quant à lui de couverture au tueur
c'est le seul membre du commando qui
manqueraient aux policiers selon eux le
tireur serait yvan colonna un berger
fils d'un ancien député des alpes
maritimes
la famille est abasourdi l'ex compagne
d'yvan colonna assure que le soir du
crime
ils étaient en sa compagnie je n'ai pas
vécu avec un assassin et séné ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas pour moi ce n'est pas
un c'est un jeune il n'était pas là ce
soir là point il était à la maison et
garder son fils du vivant colonna a
quitté sa maison samedi en expliquant à
sa famille qu'il partait dans les
alpages
depuis plus de nouvelles et policiers le
cherche depuis trois jours les juges
ont délivré à son encontre un mandat
d'arrêt les interpellations dans l'
enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac et huit personnes sont toujours
entendus à la division nationale
antiterroriste à paris
quatre autres personnes ont été en
revanche relâché aujourd'hui à ajaccio
des auditions centré autour d'un relevés
téléphoniques qui auraient révélé la
présence de plusieurs nationalistes
corses près de l'endroit où l'ancien
préfet a été assassiné au moment des
faits explication pierre didier en trois
jours les policiers avaient interpellé
treize personnes en corse du sud dans la
région de cargèse et hier autour
d'ajaccio vendredi 8 des interpellés ont
été transférés à paris où ils sont
placés en garde à vue dans les locaux de
la division nationale antiterroriste
seules quatre personnes ont été
relâchées 3 ajaccio et une femme à paris
parente d'un des hommes toujours placé
en garde à vue sous l'autorité de ce
commissaire roger marion les policiers
de l'antiterrorisme s'intéresserait tout
particulièrement à un des hommes
interpellés vendredi à son domicile
alain ferrandi de source policière il
est tenu comme un homme clé du dossier
erignac
ce nationaliste de 39 ans est notamment
interrogé sur son emploi du temps au
soir de l'assassinât du préfet des
relevés d'appels téléphoniques
indiquerait que ferrandi et d'autres
suspects se trouvaient le 6 février 1998
à proximité du lieu de l'assassinât
ce qui n'était pas d'épreuve
fondamentale ya quelques mois semble
nous aujourd'hui nous est proposé comme
des vérités intangibles techniquement
dans une petite ville comme ajaccio ou
le lait
le grand axe d'ajaccio quelques
centaines de mètres maximum mon petit
kilomètre le borgne des portables qui
identifierait les personnes pratiquement
quelques mètres près pour ne pas dire à
quelques centimètres près me semble une
interprétation à usage de grandes cités
de grandes villes comme paris ou
visiblement ça peut passer mais pour la
corse ça ne passe pas les enquêteurs
soupçonneraient également ferrandi
d'avoir été en contact avec jean castela
enseignants bastié mis en examen pour
l'attentât de strasbourg contre l'ena
les deux hommes étant présentés par des
sources policières comme les chefs d'une
des six danses du flnc canal historique
reste que jusqu'à maintenant une seule
personne est mise en examen par le juge
bruguière dans le cadre de l' enquête
sur l'assassinât du préfet erignac il
s'agit de mathieu filidori soupçonné
d'avoir rédigé des textes de
revendication
philidor qui nie farouchement son
implication dans l'assassinât du préfet
en tout cas michel toutes ces
révélations interviennent quelques
heures avant le dépôt à l'assemblée
nationale d'une motion de censure de
l'opposition l'opposition qui avait déjà
fait de la faire bonne et un de ses
principaux cheval de bataille et qui a
du mal aujourd'hui à croire à une simple
coïncidence côté majorité et
gouvernement bien évidemment on se
félicite du succès de la police jean
baptiste prêts dédiés et jacques gérard
nous résume les réactions recueillies ce
matin à paris
la nouvelle a presque pris au dépourvu
l'assemblée dans les couloirs tout le
monde salue les résultats de l' enquête
sur le meurtre du préfet erignac
pour la majorité cette satisfaction
ressemble à du soulagement
la politique de rétablissement de l'état
de droit en corse conduite depuis deux
ans portés à plus de bras et est
hypothéquée par le non aboutissement de
l' enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
aujourd'hui cette hypothèque élevé c'est
un progrès considérable la droite
préparé pour cet après midi sa motion de
censure sur la corse
officiellement les plus concernées se
réjouissent aussi une chape de plomb qui
pesait sur le dossier corse
du fait de cette affaire non élucidée
parmi une multitude d'autres donc
aujourd'hui il ya une réponse à une
attente profonde et je pense que
personne ne peut contester l'idée que
justice soit faite
mais derrière la probation ont souligné
les coïncidences l' enquête aboutit
alors que le gouvernement était en
difficulté sur la corse et l'opposition
reste critique aussi monsieur
chevénement ouvre les bouteilles de
champagne pour saluer une victoire de la
police alors dans ce moment à ce moment
là lorsque un préfet ait pris si je le
dise dans une sale affaire comme la
sphère des paillotes à ce moment là
monsieur chevénement aurait dû
démissionner ce qu'a fait la police
judiciaire aujourd'hui on peut s'en
féliciter parce que non seulement on
aboutit mais ça montre qu'il faut
toujours respecter les lois de la
république
l'opposition comptait sur le débat de
motion de censure pour mettre en cause
la politique du gouvernement en corse
l'un de ses arguments les lenteurs dans
l' enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
l'argument est tombé et le climat a
changé en corse bien sûr c'est le
soulagement qui prédomine et l'on se
félicite que l'anc est enfin abouti
notamment au sein du manifeste pour la
vie à mouvement lancé par les femmes
corse au lendemain de l'assassinât de
claude erignac
dans la famille nationaliste en revanche
on reste discret certains s'interrogent
même aujourd'hui sur les aveux du
commando hier à paris des réactions
réunis par alain chabod la corse comme
bien souvent partagés entre scepticisme
affiché et incrédulité murmuré face à
une enquête qui traînait les pieds face
au coup de filet qui longtemps s'étaient
multipliés jusqu'à ce dénouement soudain
en pleine crise des paillotes ici
pourtant chacun reste prudent comme les
militants du manifeste pour la vie qui
avait rassemblé contre la violence
quarante mille personnes dans les rues
d'ajaccio et de bastia au lendemain de
l'assassinât du préfet s'il est avéré
que le meurtre du préfet erignac est
élucidé nous espérons que toute la
vérité sera faite là-dessus mais nous
espérons aussi que c'est le début d'une
nouvelle pratique que l'on élucidera les
autres meurtres qu'ils nous entendent
est en deuil et ces dernières années que
l'on ira au bout des enquêtes
financières
je crois que c'est à cette seule
condition que la corse va sortir de du
trouble et de l'ornière côté politique
la droite aux commandes dans l'île
attend que justice soit faite dit elle
pour se déterminer pleinement et le camp
nationaliste divisés sur le recours à la
violence condamne si elle est avérée une
telle dérive d'anciens militants
nous sommes tristes de voir une telle
radicalisation a pu avoir lieu et
et nous disons qu il faut à tout prix
dégager une ligne politique majoritaire
pour éviter que ce genre d'opération et
d'affaires une affaire dont chacun ici
attend les suites judiciaires avec une
attention soutenue pour la ligne de
défense encore trouble qui sera celle
des accusés le démantèlement du commando
d assassin présumé du préfet erignac
intervient après une enquête sans
précédent
le ministre de l'intérieur a de nouveau
remercié aujourd'hui tous les
responsables de la police qui ont permis
l'arrestation du commando et il s'est
félicité de cette victoire pour la corse
c'était cet après midi à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale on les écoute et
une éclatante victoire pour la corse une
éclatante victoire pour la république
pour l'état républicain et je pense que
tous ici sur ces bancs vous en mesurer
la portée
car depuis plus de 15 mois peser
lourdement sur l'avenir de la corse et
sur l'avenir de la république ce meurtre
odieux sauvage et jusqu'à présent non
élucidées je voudrais cependant rappelé
qu'il a fallu plus de six ans pour
élucider les conditions de l'assassinât
du juge michel
je crois que le temps des enquêtes n'est
pas le temps des médias et n'est pas non
plus le temps de la politique
politicienne monsieur le ministre en
corse au plan judiciaire à ajaccio
nouvelle audi sentent du colonel mazères
qui a été mise en examen pour le premier
incendie des paillotes ce matin le juge
a décidé de maintenir en détention l'ex
préfet bonnet et puis dans la région de
cargèse un dispositif de contrôle sur
terre et sur mer se met progressivement
en place pour tenter de mettre un terme
à la fuite d'yvan colonna assassin
présumé du préfet erignac
agnès gardait olivier théron frédéric
faure
à quelques kilomètres de cargèse
les premiers barrages de gendarmerie
viennent d'être mises en place à
l'entrée et à la sortie du village
depuis la fuite d'yvan colonna la
présence policière était plutôt discrète
cet après midi ses vedettes sont venus
renforcer un dispositif encore très
léger comme en a décidé le gouvernement
les recherches semblent très discrète
c'est voulu le dispositif a été mis en
place avec mon accord et le ministre de
l'intérieur de rappelé yvan colonna la
reddition alors que le village de
cargèse semble se repliant encore un peu
plus sur lui même pendant ce temps
ajaccio il était question de l' autre
affaire celle des paillotes le colonel
henry mazères est arrivé par un vol
militaire en début de matinée
entendu par le juge patrice cambérou
pendant plus de trois heures le colonel
mazères est resté d'après son avocat sur
ses premiers aveux incendie de la
paillote chez francis et de la paillote
aria marina pour laquelle il émet une
deuxième fois en examen il reconnaît
avoir participé mais sur ordre du préfet
bonnet effets sont des tables et les
reconnaît je ne dirais pas il les
revendique
il les assume courageusement et avec
honneur il aimerait je le répète que ce
sens de l'honneur soit partagée au terme
de cette audition rien n'a filtré sur
l'existence ou non d'une enquête
parallèle menée par l'ancien préfet sur
l'affairé erignac
or plusieurs gendarmes de l'ex gps le
groupe de pelotons de sécurité entendu
comme témoin dans la sphère des
paillotes ont reconnu avoir été
sollicité par leur hiérarchie pour
travailler sur l'affairé erignac comme
ce sous-officier qui cite la
surveillance d'un certain ferrandi ou
encore celui ci membre également de l'ex
gps évoquant la sphère castella bernard
bonnet lui a qualifié de fable cette
enquête parallèle
l'ancien préfet dont la demande de mise
en liberté a été aujourd'hui rejeter les
rapports parlementaires celui du sénat
comme celui de l'assemblée nationale sur
la corse provoque une belle polémique
quant au rôle des renseignements
généraux dans la fuite d'yvan colonna
l'assassin présumé du préfet erignac
on se souvient que lors d'une audition
le patron de la police judiciaire roger
marion selon les sénateurs a mis en
cause les rg
roger marion a démenti le sénateur
michel charasse a confirmé le parquet de
paris serait en train d'étudier les
notes des parlementaires et puis ce soir
charles pasqua déclare à marseille
je crois que monsieur mario est un très
grand policier la querelle actuelle est
totalement débile dit monsieur pasqua et
je n'imagine pas du tout qu yvan colonna
ait pu être prévenus par les services de
police et le père d' yvan colonna est
intervenu aujourd'hui pour accuser de
mensonge monsieur roger marion en
reprochant ministre jean pierre
chevènement de soutenir ce dernier pour
france 2 olivier théron et frédéric
besson ont rencontré monsieur colonna en
corse
ça fait presque sept mois depuis le 23
mai dernier qui vend colonna le
meurtrier présumé du préfet a pris le
maquis à cargèse son père jean hugues
colonna l'ancien député mise en cause
par roger marion devant la commission d'
enquête parlementaire a décidé de sortir
de sa réserve pour se défendre il n'a
jamais été prévenus que l' enquête
s'orientait vers son fils et il trouve
ces allégations injurieuses hier c'était
les accusations de bonnet aujourd'hui
viennent celles de monsieur mario moi je
vous dis je suis très catégorique
ces deux fonctionnaires en manque
tous les deux on manque voilà deux
fonctionnaires qui mettent au service
exclusif de leurs ambitions de leurs
rancoeurs de leurs conflits
interpersonnels telles ou telles
accusations portées sur des citoyens
pour jean-hugues colonna les faits
viennent démentir les propos de roger
marion puisque yvan s'est enfui
uniquement lorsqu'il a su que ses
complices avaient été arrêtés ils
savaient qu'ils étaient surveillés
il le savait mais quoi qu'il en soit
quand bien même une information nous
auraient été données aux m'aurait été
donné ce qui est faux je l' ai déjà dit
je vois pas pourquoi yvan ne leur est
pas utilisé pour partir avant
l'arrestation des autres jean hugues
colonna et sa femme
au delà des péripéties de ces derniers
jours attendent espèrent un signe de
leur fils
cavale pour comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer jean hugues colonna aussi demandé
le jour où son fils est localisée à
pouvoir lui parler avant que la police
intervienne jour vous l'attendez où vous
le redouter ce jour où on vous dira
voilà votre fils est localisée je peux
pas répondre à cette question
c'est le jour venu que je serai s'il
fallait redouté à atteindre alors en
prévision de ce jour là jean hugues
colonna a pris trois avocats pour
préparer une défense à son fils il y
aura des actions violentes la prédiction
et de françois santoni l'ancien leader
de la coupe coltat le bras politique du
flnc affirme qu'il faut prendre très au
sérieux les menaces d'armata corsa le
groupe séparatiste clandestins corses
mais françois santoni réagit également
et il n'est pas le seul à la lettre d'
yvan colonna dans laquelle l'assassin
présumé du préfet erignac clame son
innocence commentaires juliette bout
parce qu'il s'est exprimé dans une
lettre manuscrite l'ennemi public numéro
1 provoque depuis hier de vives
réactions comme celle de l'ancien
secrétaire général d'à côté
indépendantiste a qui trouvent ce
courrier misérable je le préférais pour
lui qui se présente devant la presse
même de manière quand même à la main et
de se soumettre au peu de questions
quant à jean pierre chevènement il
affirme yvan colonna est un lâche il
parle même d'un abandon de la
souveraineté nationale charles pasqua
enfonce le clou le gouvernement a déjà
piqué déclare-t-il
on parle du plan jospin il vaudrait
mieux dire tout simplement le plan des
nationalistes face à ces attaques
directes sur l'avant projet de loi sur
la corse le gouvernement se concentre
sur l' affaire colonna
l'idéal pour lui c'est d'aller devant le
juge d'instruction parce que la limite
s'exprimer comme ça c'est c'est presque
ce présumé coupable alors qu'il est
présumé innocent il doit être jugé par
un tribunal correctionnel
il se présente vraiment pour se
présenter la lettre d' yvan colonna
donnera lieu à de nouvelles
investigations qui devrait alourdir le
dossier d'instruction le procès pourrait
avoir lieu avant le printemps 2002 yvan
colonna pourra t'il se rendre à la
justice sans avocats n'excluent pas
entièrement cette hypothèse et plaide
pour une éventuelle reddition de celui
qui est soupçonné de l'assassinât du
préfet erignac stéphane lissner
il signe yvan colonna patriotes
recherché en fuite depuis deux ans
l'assassin présumé du préfet erignac a
choisi d'écrire pour se manifester en
langue corse
il prétend n'être pour rien dans
l'assassinât du préfet puis il affirme
clairement la justice française au
service de l'éradication du mouvement
national je ne pense pas un instant me
mettre entre ses mains pour yvan colonna
donc pas question d'une reddition
pourtant c'est ce que réclame
aujourd'hui son avocat mais sous
certaines conditions
moi je 2 je dois lui demander de se
rendre si je peux garantir en tant que
défenseur les conditions d'un procès
équitable dont un juge impartial
indépendant il serait préférable pour
lui qu'il se présente pour se défendre
et pour contester les charges de
l'accusation
la lettre adressée à l'hebdomadaire
nationalistes ou ribombu a été
authentifié par sa famille mais pas
encore par la police une missive qui a
le don d'exaspérer les politiques
jean pierre chevènement a qualifié yvan
colonna de lâches
la ministre de la justice attend elle
devoir colonna devant les jours encore
personne n'a réagi
seul françois santoni ancienne figure du
nationalisme y voit un message clair sur
fond dames liste on a dû promettre
annuler lui promettent comme aux autres
un une éventuelle amnistie
moi je m'enquiers qu'écrivain colonnes
il ya deux jours savoir qu'il ne se
rendrait pas je pense que ce serait la
décision la plus judicieuse pour lui
aujourd'hui
six des sept membres du commando présumé
responsable de l'assassinât du préfet
sont sous les verrous
yvan colonna lui pour toujours et nous
retrouvons madame erignac bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct
madame erignac comment réagissez vous
aux propos que vous avez entendu ces
derniers jours sur l'amnistié
j'aurai je ré
je suis très choqué et ensuite je trouve
inadmissible qu'on reparle l'aministie
vraiment jeu j'en ai déjà parlé souvent
et je suis passé déjà la télévision à ce
propos et j'aurais voulu être assuré et
je vois que tout ça est reparti comme
avant on reparle des mêmes choses
mon mari était l'homme qui a été
assassiné était mon mari et mon mari
était un préfet un préfet de la
république un homme d'état de l'état
français et il était le représentant du
gouvernement en corse
donc ça représente beaucoup de choses et
je trouve qu'on devrait parler tout le
temps de non amnistie et non d'aministie
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
c'est une question qui revient trop
régulièrement précisément à chaque été
au moment où les nationalistes se
réunissent oui et je trouve que ça se
passe toujours l'été où les gens sont en
vacances au au fond l amnistie la nonne
amnistie est une chose grave et on parle
d'un
théâtre politique de l'été vous savez
moi je trouve que tous aillent beaucoup
à beaucoup de mépris pour nous je le
ressens comme ça
vous aviez reçu des assurances de lionel
jospin et de jacques chirac est ce que
vous vous y croyez toujours écouté
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils me le disent
ça me rassurerait voilà c'est le message
que vous aurez c'est ce soir à lionel
jospin et jacques sherwin et à jacques
chirac exactement ça me rassurait
beaucoup et j'en ai besoin
merci beaucoup madame d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir l'hommage d'ajaccio ce
matin au préfet erignac à l'endroit même
où il a été assassiné par balles
il y a tout juste quatre ans une plaque
a été dévoilée en sa mémoire
plus de 300 personnes ont assisté à son
inauguration
au même moment paris commémorait aussi
cet anniversaire funèbres
l'occasion pour dominique erignac sa
veuve d'en appeler aux candidats à la
présidence afin que l'assassin de son
mari soit enfin arrêté j'ai toujours
demandé interpellé
et
le président de la république et
et le premier ministre parce que mon
mari est un préfet il fait partie de
l'état et et ils vont être candidat
l'enquète sur le meurtre de claude
érignac le 6 février 98 abouti à
l'arrestation de huit nationalistes
corses mais son assassin présumé yvan
colonna demeure introuvable
la justice est tenue en échec mais
lionel jospin réaffirme lui son
optimisme je ne doute pas que la justice
de mon pays que les forces dé sécurité
y parviendront ce jour là yvan colonna
assassin présumé aura à rendre des
comptes à la justice
le procès des membres du commando à 16,5
devrait avoir lieu à la fin de cette
année en attendant la traque divan
colonna continue au procès des assassins
présumés du préfet erignac plusieurs
accusés se sont rétractés et ont tenté
jeudi
dinnosanté le tueur présumé yvan colonna
des déclarations qui ont conduit la
veuve du préfet madame dominique erignac
à s'exprimer pour la première fois
depuis le début du procès sur place
dominique verdeilhan et matthew birbeck
les accusés eux-mêmes rendent hommage à
la dignité de dominique erignac
chaque jour le face à face est tendue
mais respectueux ce matin quatre des
accusés ont mis hors de cause yvan
colonna pour eux il n'est pas l'assassin
du préfet j'ai du mal à la croire
comment ce qu'on peut avouer d'une
manière si précises et puis tu n'es que
se rétracter je ne comprends pas il se
rétracte devant des actes collectifs
tout ça m'apparaît bien facile ce sont
des hommes qui ont sont pas des enfants
ce sont des hommes qui en quarante ans
et qui ont décidé de faire quelque chose
vient jusqu'à tel nom de quoi
oui les corses revendique beaucoup être
des hommes d'honneur je pense que là je
trouve qu'il manque d'honneur et de
panache on ne tue pas quelqu'un parce
qu'il est préfet qu'il représente
quelque chose
la vie est quelque chose de plus
important de 2 on ne peut pas faire ça
je les ai beaucoup regardé dans les yeux
d'ailleurs elles ont baissé les yeux
mais maintenant je n'ai pas envie de les
regarder
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
leur dire non aux îles tonga se défend
disons qu'à dire ce qu'ils ont à dire
non moi je n'ai pas envie de parler
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la suite
ceux possédant encore durer trois
semaines
oui en ce moment je ne s'avoue que je
suis un peu désespéré jeu j'aimerais
bien qu'ils aient que le procès avance
et que l'on trouve pas être une réponse
madame monsieur bonsoir yvan colonna
l'assassin présumé du préfet claude
erignac à ajaccio en 1998 a été arrêté
ce vendredi en fin d'après midi il se
trouvait dans une bergerie près de porto
pollo en corse du sud
cette arrestation intervient après cinq
semaines de procès des autres coupables
présumés de cet assassinat et 48 heures
avant la tenue du référendum sur le
statut de l'île
les circonstances de son interpellation
et ving goldman
on le croyait en fuite à l'étranger mais
c'est sur sa terre natale qui vont
colonna s'était réfugié c'est dans une
bergerie comme celle ci que les hommes
du raid ont arrêté la police surveillait
depuis près de quatre heures au lieu-dit
de margarita gars quand yvan colonna
leur est apparu très différent de ces
images il portait une barbe et des
cheveux longs et s'apprêtait à
disparaître dans le maquis vendredi vers
19 heures les hommes du raid se sont
approchés de lui
yvan colonna oui c'est moi at il
simplement répondu
et c'est ainsi que s'est achevée quatre
ans de cavale de l'homme le plus
recherché de france ce soir l'avocat d'
yvan colonna s'est déclarée indignée par
les déclarations du ministre de
l'intérieur
désignant yvan colonna comme l'assassin
du préfet erignac
entre eux elle consiste à défendre nos
colonnes et faire en sorte que d'abord
sa présomption d'innocence sont
respectifs qui n'a pas été le cas ce
soir 20h cosy qui fait une déclaration
qui va à l'encontre du principe de
présomption d'innocence alors que
monsieur chirac vient d'affirmer ce
principe devant la conférence des
bâtonniers
mais je pense que quand il fait
référence à ce principe dans la forêt
bâtonnier ne pense plus à lui-même qu'à
monsieur colonna yvan colonna devraient
être transférés à paris cette nuit pour
être présenté à un juge antiterroriste
tout de suite je vous propose d'écouter
les premières réactions de nicolas
sarkozy c'était il ya quelques instants
la police française vient d'arrêter yvan
colonna l'assassin
[Applaudissements]
force est restée à la loi est la loi de
la république
oui ya vraiment quelque chose qui ait
changé dans notre république c'est que
maintenant nous faisons ce que nous
disons et vous permettez de vous dire
quelque chose je pense à cet instant une
personne plus exactement à trois
personnes à madame erignac qui a tant
souffert à son fils et à sa fille et
cette arrestation
je veulent alors étudié aujourd'hui
maintenant ils vont pouvoir commencer le
deuil de ce grand homme qui a été le
préfet erignac
voilà la conception de métal rare que la
nôtre
j'aurais qu'on en vienne à l'information
essentielle de ce journal on appris via
une dizaine de minutes yvan colonna est
arrêté par le raid en corse du sud yvan
colonna vous le savez est soupçonné
d'être le tueur du préfet erignac
son arrestation intervient à quelques
jours de la fin du procès erignac
si vous voulez bien on va d'abord
retracé le parcours et la fuite d'yvan
colonna avec stéphane breitner trois
balles en pleine tête
une exécution froide metodi
claude erignac représentait l'état il en
est mort le 6 février 98
21h il quitte la préfecture pour se
rendre au théâtre sans escorte comme
d'habitude 600 mètres plus loin le
préfet garé sa voiture puis remonte la
rue vers la salle de spectacle
pour l'accusation deux hommes
l'attendent yvan colonna chargé de tirer
et pierre alessandri en couverture
lorsque le préfet les dépasse yvan
colonna sort son arme et ouvre le feu
dans une rue adjacente martin ottaviani
récupère les deux hommes et prend la
fuite
un an plus tard les membres du commando
sont arrêtés grâce aux relevés de leur
téléphone portable tous sauf un
yvan colonna qu il voulait distille
créer un électrochoc chez les
nationalistes et pour la corse
ce n'était pas un acte irrationnel lien
est de droit commun c'est un art qui se
veut politique donc il faut essayer de
comprendre rétroactivement comment une
telle action tels que at elle pu se
mettre en place à un moment donné une
idée relayée par une partie des
nationalistes depuis un mois mais pour
la famille erignac
pas question de mélanger les genres on
juge des assassins présumés ses hommes
tout à coup se sont réunis pour
commettre
le crime le plus odieux que l'on puisse
commettre d'une manière qui relève
malheureusement beaucoup plus d
exécution de la mafia que ce que l'on
avait vu quand même jusque là encore les
huit accusés seront également jugés pour
trois attentats en 97 dont celui de la
gendarmerie de pietrosella où a été
dérobée l'armé qui a servi à tuer le
préfet
bonsoir l'essentiel de ce journal sera
bien évidemment consacré à l'arrestation
d'yvan colonna qui a été transférée
s'est tenu à paris il devrait être mise
en examen pour l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
tout au long de cette édition nous
retracerons le détail de son
interpellation par les hommes du raid
nous ferons le récit de l'enquète mais
d'abord je vous propose de vous arrêter
un instant sur ces deux images
symboliques que quatre années de cavale
ces parcelles d' yvan colonna tel qu'on
le connaissait
voici l'homme le plus recherché de
france cette photo a été placardée dans
tous les commissariats
hier au moment de son transfert vers la
prison de la santé à paris
yvan colonna était méconnaissable
d'après les témoins et d'après la photo
que posséder nicolas sarkozy depuis
quelques jours il porte une barbe et une
moustache des cheveux longs jusqu'aux
épaules il a pris du poids
l'ancien fugitif présente une apparence
très éloignée de celle de son avis de
recherche
vingt-quatre heures après son
interpellation yvan colonna vient donc
d'être présentées à la justice
antiterroriste
voici le fil des événements depuis son
arrestation christelle bertrand
seuls les policiers ont vu son visage de
loin yvan colonna est méconnaissable
pourtant c'est bien lui l'homme aux
cheveux longs il est 2h30 du matin à
l'aéroport d'ajaccio
yvan colonna quitte son île sous les
yeux de ses amis en bout de piste les
feux de leur voiture clignote pour un
dernier salut jean guy talamoni l'élu
nationaliste a spécialement fait le
voyage de bastia ajaccio stéphane
colonna le frère du vent est là deux
heures plus tôt il était aussi devant le
commissariat
[Musique]
à ses côtés l'avocat et l'ex-compagne du
fugitif
[Applaudissements]
sans nouvelles les esprits s'échauffent
dès que des faux rebonds approche
oh la la
personne ne sait si yvan colonna était à
bord ou déjà dans les locaux de la
police
m
par dépit quelques centaines de
sympathisants s'en prennent à leurs aux
forces de l'ordre
puis peu à peu la tension redescend
yvan colonna lui est déjà loin il vole
vers le continent pour se poser sur
l'aéroport militaire de villacoublay ils
se cachent
assis à l'arrière d'un véhicule entre
deux policiers du raid
le convoi file à toute allure dans les
rues désertes de la capitale
il est 5h30 du matin le périple au divan
colonna s'interrompt quelques heures à
la prison de la santé en début d'après
midi
il est transféré au palais de justice là
encore les mesures de sécurité sont
maximales fourgon blindé home armés de
fusils à pompe
vingt-quatre heures après la fin de sa
cavale yvan colonna est entré dans le
bureau d'un juge antiterroriste
l'arrestation d' yvan colonna constitue
donc une excellente nouvelle pour le
gouvernement est d'abord pour son
ministre de l'intérieur nicolas sarkozy
avait fait de ce dossier l'un de ses
principaux objectifs une priorité
nationale selon ses propres termes
ce matin lors d'une conférence de presse
nicolas sarkozy qui a démenti toute
négociation avec yvan colonna est revenu
sur les circonstances de son arrestation
s'il y avait une reddition nous
l'aurions bien sûr parfaitement accepté
les critiques ce soit ici peut imaginer
qu'il y ait une quelconque négociation
je voudrais vous dire également une
chose c'est que le terrain était
extraordinairement difficile avec un
maquis en train med 51 m 90 parfois
d'auteur
ce qui fait que même à 30 mètres avec le
peu d'hommes finalement qu était sur le
terrain
le risque de fuite était considérable ce
qui fait d'ailleurs que pour intervenir
il a fallu qu yvan colonna sorte de
l'endroit où il se trouvait passe par un
petit sentier pour que deux
fonctionnaires puissent l'interpeller je
puis vous dire par exemple ça a été très
difficile de savoir dans lesquels des
bâtiments de la bergerie où se trouvait
il était lui-même localiser et tant que
nous ne savions pas toute intervention
était extraordinairement risqué yvan
colonna était repéré le soir du 29 juin
dernier dans cette bergerie qui sera son
dernier refuge
comment les hommes du raid ont ils
procédé pour arriver à le capturer
vivant comme l'avait promis le ministre
d'ailleurs le récit d'une arrestation
qui intervient au terme d'une longue
enquête dans le déroulement s'est
accélérée en quelques semaines tir et
kurt et l'opération vient de s'achever
ce n'est qu'à cet instant c'est à dire
tard la nuit dernière que les hommes du
raid ont la certitude de ne pas s'être
trompé
mais depuis le matin grâce à un petit
détail il espère sur le coup de 5 heures
du matin nous ne voyons rien mais on
nous informions des bouts de casseroles
et un individu qui parlait avec les
chèvres
c'est un détail capital le patron du
raid sec yvan colonna à ce genre
d'habitude depuis un an
les enquêteurs ont surveillé plus de 200
bergerie celle ci serait donc la bonne
il l'avait repéré grâce à la filature
d'un patrons des campings du littoral
dans le bâtiment il trouve un lit de
camp et des journaux récents la planque
commence dans l'épée maquis corse
il y a deux jours trente hommes du raid
sont en place ils ont en tête cette
vieille photo du fugitif et une plus
récente aussi l'homme qu'ils aperçoivent
les différents la nuit passe permis dit
l'homme sort il ne laisse partir à 19h15
deux fonctionnaires qui se trouvait
caché dans le maquis à proximité de la
propriété ont vu revenir il notre
individu il a été immédiatement
interpellé et l'a tenté de prendre la
fuite
ensuite il a été maîtrisé on l
confirmation en le regardant de près que
c'était bien yvan colonna c'est
christian lambert sur place les yeux
dans les yeux qui lui pose la question
tu es bien yvan colonna allez on t'a
reconnu arrête je suis yvan pas de
problème c'est bien moi on arrête de
jouer
vous avez bien bossé la cavale d'yvan
colonna se termine comme elle a commencé
en plein maquis corse yvan colonna a été
mis ce soir en examen pour l'assassinât
du préfet erignac
interrogé par trois juges
antiterroristes en fin d'après midi
yvan colonna a refusé de parler ce soir
il a regagné la prison de la santé
compte rendu de cette journée sophie
guihomat et casteljau riant
c'est à l'abri des regards derrière les
vitres de ce fourgon cellulaire que yvan
colonna a quitté ce soir le palais de
justice de paris
entendu une partie de l'après-midi par
trois juges antiterroristes
il a été mise en examen dans deux
dossiers l'assassinât du préfet erignac
et l'attaqué de la gendarmerie de
pietrosella en 1997
aucune déclaration n'a été faite
aujourd'hui devant les magistrats ont
stagné en somme il s'agit d'une simple
notification est mise en examen et des
charges et il n'y aura pas d'explication
des noms colonna sur les charges sur le
fond sept mille donateurs au fonds sera
reportée le temps suit arrière après que
nous ayons pu avoir mais gabarit n'est
moi connaissance du dossier un dossier
auquel ils s'attaqueront dès lundi yvan
colonna lui s'apprête à passer sa
deuxième nuit à la prison de la santé
c'est hier soir qu'il a quitté la corse
l'homme à la chemise bleue aux pantalons
clairs et aux cheveux longs c'est lui
méconnaissable après quatre ans de
cavale
son arrestation remonte alors à quelques
heures elle a eu lieu dans cette
bergerie au coeur du maquis pour
certains voisins la surprise est immense
réfectoire et suivent pas
ces nouveaux sur un cas temps c'est pas
possible je vais arriver gilles tout
l'hiver à la chasse avec des amis nous
faisons des batteries en fait paul a
toujours collé cette maison bien fermé
sans personne à l'intérieur
le propriétaire de la bergerie a été
arrêté à son tour ce matin mais il n'est
certainement pas le seul à avoir aidé
yvan colonna
pour le ministre de l'intérieur c'est
tout un réseau qu'il faut maintenant
démantelé il est certain qu'il sera plus
facile pour nous de faire un bilan
complet au moment où toutes les
arrestations ont été conduites
nous ne sommes pas encore au terme de
tout le travail strictement policiers
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
promettent donc d'être riche en
rebondissements
c'est dans une bergerie située sur une
colline au milieu du maquis près de
propriano en corse du sud yvan colonna a
été arrêté les aime du raid cerner
l'endroit au plus près depuis plusieurs
jours après l'interpellation de colonna
c'est le propriétaire de la bergerie qui
a été arrêté à l'aube
yvan colonna qui a tenté de prendre la
fuite bénéficiait semble-t-il d'un
système de complicité l'enquète le dit
ryan frontier patrice wucher voilà son
dernier refuge une petite bâtisse en
pierre cachée au milieu de la végétation
un repère isolées sur les hauteurs avec
une vue imprenable sur la vallée et la
mer en contrebas quelquesoit deux gros
chiens de berger et une bicoque en bois
où l'on fait le fromage
rien de plus un confort spartiate
pour y arriver il faut monter plus de
vingt minutes à travers le maquis sur ce
chemin sinueux et cabossé emprunter
habituellement par les troupeaux de
chèvres une bergerie qui appartient à
cette massy sur la banquette arrière le
visage masqué par un tissu
il a été arrêté chez lui tôt ce matin
est aussitôt conduit par des policiers
en civil sur les lieux de l'arrestation
eux sont des amis de ce berger ils sont
venus lui rendre visite ce matin sans
réaliser ce qui venait de se passer
et là je voudrais pour lui rendre visite
et apparemment ça se passe pas comme
j'avais prévu d'attaquer surpris
j'imagine ben ouais je sais pas trop ce
qui se passe donc joué ont été surpris
et qui ait pas du tout au courant d'une
rumeur que vous souhaites tu aurais pu
vraiment pas voilà donc où s'est achevée
la cavale d'yvan colonna
hier l'assassin présumé du préfet
erignac admirer une dernière fois ses
paysages qu'il aimait tant
avant d'être transféré en prison à paris
yvan colonna était dans le bureau du
juge antiterroriste laurence le vert cet
après midi à paris l'assassin présumé du
préfet erignac était interrogé pour la
première fois sur le fond du dossier
il clame toujours son innocence clément
weill-raynal dit sapin
rarement une arrivée au palais de
justice aura suscité un tel luxe de
précautions
le transfert d' yvan colonna se fait
sous escorte armée mais l'île de la cité
est également protégé par une
surveillance aérienne ainsi que fluvial
on n'est jamais assez prévoyants pendant
toute la journée
yvan colonna a été interrogé par le juge
d'instruction antiterroriste laurence le
vert
yvan colonna continue d'affirmer qu'il
n'est pour rien dans l'assassinât du
préfet claude erignac
pour le moment la justice ne dispose que
de deux éléments à charge les aveux des
membres du commando qui ont désigné yvan
colonna comme l'assassin du préfet et
les quatre années de clandestinité passé
dans le maquis corse
une cavale sur laquelle yvan colonna
devra forcément s'expliquer pour moi une
cape comme signe rien du tout
ce qui est ce qui doit être établi c'est
les charges précises et que ces charges
sont confrontés aux
aux déclarations des autres et je
persiste à dire qu'il n'y a aucun
élément matériel qui viennent corroborer
les déclarations qui en font c'est
qu'ils ont mises en cause
nous verrons par ailleurs aussi que se
posent d'autres problèmes nous
évoquerons vendredi matin devant la
chambre d'instruction dont quillan
colonna continue de plaider son
innocence le terme et son innocence est
innocent les avocats d yvan colonna
entendent notamment demandé une
confrontation avec les autres membres du
commando qui ont désigné yvan colonna
pendant leur garde à vue avant de se
rétracter plusieurs mois après cette
confrontation sera l'un des moments
essentiels de l'instruction
[Musique]